bloomberg's hundred million dollars
huh deciding to help his brother joe
biden
win the state of florida
okay here's what this reminds me of did
you watch the last season of curb your
enthusiasm larry david show on hbo
so larry david he goes mocha joe's a
character yeah okay
a reappearing character so mocha joe has
a coffee shop larry david goes in there
the coffee's cold the scone is too hard
the table's wobbly he's upset about it
so he opens
a store right next to it and calls it
his spite store
opens a coffee shop right next to it to
put it out of business i think this is
all
like 500 personal with bloomberg all
right he's writing this check
it'll probably be personal towards trump
yes his hatred towards trump
this is all something happened with
these guys when he was the mayor because
think of the amount of money the fortune
that he is going to spend on his
losing primary campaign and then if this
hundred million
doesn't help him out it's a spite store
on the political side of things and it's
100 personal what do you think about
that adam well obviously he doesn't like
trump i mean obviously i mean
i don't think bloomberg obviously yeah i
mean you're spending a hundred
million dollars but i'm saying the only
reason is it's
personal oh okay no i mean there's
obviously more to it
you know i'm going to give you an answer
you're probably not expecting out of a
young adam saws over here let's hear it
um
well most you know from miami florida
boy lived everywhere in florida
florida is literally the most important
state when it comes to elections agree
or disagree yes purple yes
it's purple it has the most electoral uh
college voters al gore bush
congress chad's always
you got north florida and more gop you
got south florida more democratic you
got the
cubans you got old people you got
haitians you got blacks it is the most
important state so that's why we're
going to single out this state
but here's my thoughts on this i
actually
hate seeing stories like this whether
it's on the left or whether it's on the
right
bloomberg donates a hundred million
dollars george soros donates
you know a billion dollars the koch
brothers donate
it's just a pay-for-play thing these
super pacs these
one thing for sure is if you're a
billionaire you could just buy your
elections hey
bloomberg wants to give a hundred
million dollars to florida cool the koch
brothers want to give
you know 50 billion dollars to nebraska
cool
yeah it's just so excessive and all
these
billionaires just so you're heartbroken
i'm heartbroken unless the
buying ends up i mean what's he going to
spend it on tv commercials i guess
i mean it says it right here he's going
to use it
for two reasons number one to obviously
prop up biden but number two
to make trump spend more of his campaign
chest so
you know it's like literally prop him up
yeah he's going i mean he's going to
here's the windows
question i got for you here's a question
i got for you so so he's going to spend
100 million dollars which first of all
100 million dollars
is nothing to a guy worth 65 billion
dollars that's like you having
65 000 and giving a hundred dollars to a
person running for office that's like
you having six hundred fifty thousand
dollars you're giving a thousand dollars
to him it's not a big deal and then
let's look at how much money this guy
spent on his own campaign yeah okay
he spent a losing campaign do you know
how much money spent do you know the 500
million
900 million dollars he spent on his own
campaign and he got 58 delegates
and he lasted less than barely i was
going to say i was going to say not even
a couple
but this is the point i'm trying to make
to you if i'm even gonna ask you a
crazier
question okay say he spent 64 billion
dollars
okay in the state of florida say
bloomberg hates trump so much
he gives his 65 billion dollars
to help biden get elected do you think
biden's still going to get elected if he
gives him 65 no there's no guarantee
what i'm trying to say to you is the
following as much as money matters
as much as money matters as much as you
can go out there and say well it's about
this and it's about that and it's about
this
america voted obama when obama was
coming up hillary had all the money not
obama okay
when he was coming up hillary had the
money he didn't have the money when
trump was coming up jeb bush had all the
money jeb bush day one had 140 million
dollars
trump had nothing right trump just had a
social media presence
this is more than just giving money i
think what's starting to happen today is
money matters don't get me wrong you
need the super pacs you need the money
100 but if you are not coming out just
yesterday the
trump did a rally in nevada right and
just yesterday
look at what trump's doing so yesterday
trump is in nevada
does a rally does it give us a talk i
don't think it was yes maybe it was a
day before then when he gave the talk
two days ago
he gives a talk in nevada on fire this
guy
lit up right getting up there talking
people hollering
there's 80 000 people when i was
watching it when it was alive
i was in the bathroom i'm being serious
with you
i get out of the bathroom i said babe
look how many people watching i said
there's 80
000 people watching trump in their
bathroom stall right now listen to this
guy
speak from anywhere i said when hillary
and trump were running here's what was
happening if you remember
this hitler's run against trump
every day you turn on facebook trump was
somewhere doing a rally
every day you turned on facebook you
didn't see hillary clinton do rallies
no matter how much money is spent if
biden's strategy is to lock them up
don't have
them come out don't let anybody see them
no one's going to get any opinions any
of that stuff's not going to take place
i don't care how much bloomberg spends
nothing's going to happen you know why
do you think bloomberg is such a
lightweight and so
unsuccessful nationally i mean he was i
mean the media company he built is
unbelievable when you look at bloomberg
and
and what that value is of that company
he was such a great mayor yeah i mean
you would almost think that he would
transfer over and be an outstanding
president but he's such a lightweight
i mean what is it with him nationally
people just don't identify with him
different strokes for different folks
you have a jewish billionaire who
you know made his money in new york city
he's going to resonate in new york he's
not going to resonate in but he was
saying
oklahoma he did a good job i just
thought he could do a better job in
these primaries and
and you would look at him and have a
little more respect for him but he's
kind of a putts when you think about him
i'll give you i'll give you a perfect
idea there it's a very good question you
point out by the way very good question
we're not prepared for this that's a
very good question
i will tell you this so you know how you
know how you decide to go away
and come back and reappear in the media
okay like reinvent yourself yeah no
not even reinvent you kind of like when
you have the money sometimes you're
getting all the attention all this other
stuff
you get to a point where you don't want
any attention right
because sometimes you don't want
attention because you don't want your
personal life to be
a target on your back like how many
times you see jordan doing an interview
honestly never how often do you see
michael jordan do an interview not even
as the owner he doesn't do it what was
the most common thing when jordan was in
chicago and they would ask him about his
personal life what would michael say to
the internet like people like you what
would he say
uh he would deflect aaa you probably
won't even ask him that question because
you know it's pretty much but if you
did it was a code in chicago you don't
ask michael about his personal life
but if you did michael point-blank will
look at you and he would say
you know i'm here to talk about
basketball my personal life said it i
don't want to talk about it but my
basketball life whatever questions we
got we can talk about it so he deflected
why
some of these guys just don't want your
personal life to be advertised right so
bloomberg
is so big in new york he's the mayor all
this other stuff
then maybe his marriage didn't work out
he's a single guy he's got the money
he's got girlfriends on the side i don't
want publicity
then he decides to go out and get on
social media which i'll tell you how
many followers he has on social media
and this stuff matters today it didn't
matter 40 years ago
but it matters today watch this
bloomberg on instagram
has 468 000 followers let me say this
one more time adam
bloomberg on instagram has 468 000
followers
that is less than many 12 year olds that
are putting cat videos on instagram he's
not even
and he's running for office his last
video he posted this morning
got 2583 views in two hours
with 19 comments and this guy's worth 65
billion dollars
what this tells you for for this for
right here
is the big screen he is not fit for the
big screen
he's fit for the boardroom it's a very
big difference today's presidential to
win
you got to belong here he doesn't belong
there not bloomberg that's my opinion i
wonder how many of those posts he does
on his own do you think he
that's the beauty of trump and some of
these other people you can tell that
bloomberg
he's a twitter finger filter right and
it's a real message that's getting out
yeah i mean look like you said some
something must have happened in new york
and you know
would you be surprised that trump has
bloomberg i mean
how long is the list of people that
trump is pissed off can we add just
bloomberg to that list it's not like
it's a big deal
and depends how thin your skin is
because at some point trump's going to
say something about you so do you hold a
grudge yeah you take it that personally
yeah
he's not he's not cool with that so
apparently that that's not something
he's uh comfortable with but
we'll see what's gonna happen with that
hundred million dollars